members of the committee investigating
the january 6 attack on the capitol say
explosive new information will come to
light during prime time public hearings
tomorrow we shall see robert costa joins
us now from washington
bob good morning before we get into what
might come to light at these hearings
talk to us a bit about what the
committee is trying to accomplish good
morning tony the committee is trying to
tell a story and they have a challenge
here on one front they want to update
the american people and also jolt them
about what actually happened on january
6 2021 in terms of the attack on the
capital the brutal reality of the
violence that day on a second front
they're trying to bring
some light on the legal and political
crusade spearheaded by then president
trump to try to overturn the 2020
election and it's that latter point
that's a little more complicated because
it involves so many players
all right we've got 300 interviews we've
got 50 subpoenas 35 000 pages of records
they've gone through it's a torrent of
information do they have anything new in
there
they do have new testimony that's coming
from both video they've recorded from
depositions they're also going to have
live witnesses a capital police officer
a documentary filmmaker who was with
members of the proud boys and oath
keepers on the eve of the insurrection
and they're going to have a composite
presentation that tries to bring that
all together we've seen the images we've
seen the videos what this committee is
doing working with a television producer
is to try to remind people about what
exactly happened put it in chronological
order and bring people into the story
tony mentioned the thousand witnesses um
are you looking forward to anyone in
particular to be watching for
you think back almost 50 years nate to
the watergate hearings in 1973
sometimes it's not the people you know
but the people you don't know that
really surprise you and this time around
i'm looking for someone who's a
little-known player to bring some new
information to the fore one of those
people could be cassidy hutchinson who's
a former aide to former trump chief of
staff mark meadows she has been
cooperating with the committee she could
be in a sense the so-called alexander
butterfield of these january six
hearings alexander butterfield during
the watergate hearings in 1973 brought a
lot of new information out about the
nixon white house cassidy hutchinson
she's a younger aide who's not a lot of
people know but she was there as they
say in hamilton in the room with meadows
former president trump
well bob thank you very much and nate
you're right more than a thousand
witnesses i lost track at 300.
we'll see what they got in prime time
bob thank you again